bonjour ce que je vais vous présenter
est assez simple en fait c'est comme une
équation peut trouver très rapidement la
solution de plus 2 par contre ce qui en
découle va peut-être un peu dérangée va
peut-être être pas tout de suite à
digérer va pas être facile à accepter qu
effectivement c'est ça qui en découlent
du coup c'est peut-être important
d'abord savoir qui chutent on m'a déjà
présenté brièvement mais j'ai donc fait
des études de médecine pour commencer
parce que moi s'ils comptaient dans la
vie c'était d'aider les autres de faire
en sorte qu'ils soient guéris qu'ils
puissent se réparer les bras à voir dans
leur quotidien une vie saine quelque
chose qui fasse que chacun sent bien et
donc je me lance dans la médecine j'ai
envie de faire la chirurgie orthopédique
et après 4 ans 4e médecine on a un bac
es là chamboulement
on sait plus ce qu'on veut faire et
surtout on se rend compte que la
médecine est très dépendante de plein de
choses
la médecine en fait dépend de l'énergie
qui fait avancer des ambulances
l'énergie qui fait allumer toutes les
lumières à l'hôpital dépend aussi des
déchets qui doivent être triés traité du
coup je change d'objectif
je me dirige vers les études d'ingénieur
civil et moi mon nouvel objectif c'est
les nouvelles technologies
j'ai envie d'aider tout le monde allait
mieux faire en sorte que à l'hôpital on
puisse aller mieux mais que même dans
tous les autres secteurs les gens
puissent se retrouver le confort qu'on a
aujourd'hui la facilité de vivre ceci à
travers des technologies qui ne polluent
pas notre environnement qui ne
détruisent pas la terre afin que moi mes
enfants vous puissiez vivre aussi dans
cette planète dans les années à venir
du coup je me lance dans ces questions
et mon mémoire en ingère civile afin de
repousser les limites au bout je me dis
pour terminer mes études j'ai essayé de
voir jusqu'où on pourra aller quels
seront les meilleures technologies qu'on
pourra mettre en place et qu'elles sont
est l'heure limite aussi
et du coup il ya deux grandes questions
qui ressort de mon travail de fin
d'études j'ai envie de vous partager
premièrement ce sera quelles sont les
sources d'énergie qu'on a aujourd'hui
et vers où on peut aller dans le futur
et puis deuxièmement mais pour qu'on a
besoin d'énergie parce qu'on parle
toujours de haut il faut de l'énergie
pour 6 pour ça en fait pourquoi on
trouverait pas des manières de vivre
sans énergie les coûts premièrement
commençons par des énergies qu'on a
aujourd'hui on je vous ai préparé avec
les chiffres de bp
il faut les trouver sur internet aussi
un graphique qui a montré par tranches
de 5 % les 100% énergies qu'on a
aujourd'hui
du coup on peut commencer avec les cinq
premiers pour cent qui sont des énergies
fossiles
c'est le pétrole entre autres puis on
peut passer au prochain 5% et on
retrouve du charbon par exemple puis
entre continue on trouve du gaz en fait
vous est peut-être plus de comprendre on
trouve surtout que des énergies fossiles
jusqu'à 86%
on trouve des énergies fossiles partout
dans notre quotidien pour faire avancer
une voiture ça fait déjà un petit froid
on se dit à ce passé énergie là qu'on
voulait entendre
du coup 60% 70% il ya des marées noires
qui se créent à cause de ces énergies là
et le réchauffement climatique qui
aujourd'hui paraît quand même quelque
chose de primordial à régler les couches
j'arrive à mes 86% et puis après je
trouve heureusement les énergies
nucléaires qui nous amène à 91 1% puis
enfin l'hydraulique qui sont des grandes
structures qui sont là depuis longtemps
et même nouvelles technologies celles
pour lesquelles j'étais dedans c'est
dans mes études d'ingénieur les 2 25%
restants c'est un peu vous allez me dire
mais pourquoi pas le temps 2 j'ai été
chercher surveille sur google on parle
que de ça on fait énergie et regardez
vous avez trouvé que des énergies
renouvelables vient pas de problème
qu'en rire google mais c'est en fait que
si on reprend cette notion du fait que
86 % de nos énergies sont des énergies
fossiles sortir de ce problème
climatique sortir de cette consommation
d'énergie fossile va nécessiter une
diminution de notre consommation
d'énergie
on pourra pas remplacer du jour au
lendemain c'est saxe c'est ça qu'elle 17
courant et c'est pour ça qu'on se fausse
un peu la question en parlant tout le
temps de ces énergies renouvelables on
va essayer de reprendre une métaphore on
va se simplifier tout ça imaginez qu'un
on a une énorme corne d'abondance qui
nous envoie d'énergie quotidiennement
s'appelle le soleil
représentée ici par un robinet qui nous
envoie de l'eau mais humain au début de
l'humanité ont découvert qu'ils
pouvaient petit à petit utiliser cette
énergie en faisant utilisé avant le vent
pourra faire avancer leur bateau en
mangeant les plantes en travaillant avec
les bêtes ce qu'ils mangent et les
plantes qui venait du soleil bref cette
énergie nous permettait de vivre
sainement mais grâce au génie humain on
a trouvé des autres énergies qui en fait
sont le soleil qui a envoyé d'énergie
depuis 200 millions deux cent millions
d'années même c'est le pétrole de gaz
charbon qui sont des stocks qui ont été
placés sous terre grâce aux à lafitte
photosynthèse qui s'est transformé en d
énorme poche de l'énergie qui sont sous
terre cette énergie là les humains sont
dit assez rapidement mais on va et on va
en voir aussi on va aussi à les utiliser
petit à petit on a commencé à vider ses
stocks de bouteilles on a commencé à
utiliser de plus en plus d'énergie de
faire des voitures qui voulaient
réellement pas avec un petit cheval qui
tirait notre charrette mais on se rend
compte que d'un côté c'est limité et
donc on voit la quantité qui diminue
mais le plus difficile c'est qu'on doit
arrêter avant qu'on arrive à la fin
et là ça complique les choses c'est
qu'on doit se dire qu'on passe à un
autre mode de vie on va lui c'est plus
que un petit verre et qu'on va laisser
les autres sous terre et là on doit
dépasser notre propre envie d'aller d
utiliser et de laisser de passer à un
mode un mode de vie sans énergie que mon
aujourd'hui mais du coup deuxième
conclusion deuxième question de mon
mémoire
à quoi ça sert l'énergie ont pesé se
dire mais c'est pas grave
et là ça commence puisse à ce point
c'est l'énergie en fait ça permet de
transformer les choses ça permet de
transformer la matière ça permet de
faire en sorte qu'un moteur ton
fonctionne par exemple et donc six mois
toute l'énergie qu'ils utilisent tous
les jours comme par exemple dans ma
voiture je devais la remplacer par
quelque chose d'autre qui transforme les
choses il y aurait à des ingénieurs qui
parle du coût d'esclaves énergétique
parce que ça donne une image
en fait toute notre énergie aujourd'hui
cij a remplacé par des êtres humains qui
travaillait à ma place à la place des
énergies du consomment et ses esclaves
énergétique pourrait s'appeler pétrole
gaz ou autre eh ben ça représenterait
400 vies 20 milliards dus
un qui travaille pour nous on a chacun
60 personnes qui travaillent pour nous
aujourd'hui caché dans ces énergies
fossiles surtout donc 67 moyenne en
belgique on est plutôt à 400 je vous
avoue mais passons la suite en fait des
économistes aussi de décrire cela les
systèmes graf qui a été fait par gaël
giraud requis un canot mist français qui
en fait des criques
si on se comprend que l'énergie permet
de transformer les choses et qui permet
de faire des choses en fait l'énergie
décrit très bien la richesse et pouvoir
d'achat que nous avons et on voit une
corrélation quasi exacte tout pile entre
la richesse que nous possédons au niveau
mondial et l'énergie que nous consommons
au niveau mondial donc on vient de
parler de diminution de l'énergie ça
pose une grande question sur la richesse
que nous avons du coup en fait la
deuxième conclusion même mémoire parlait
de diminution totale de la richesse
mondiale s'appelle la décroissance eux
c'était pas très drôle mais moi naïf
comme j'étais en tant qu'ingénieur je me
suis dit je vais aller à l'onu
j'étais représentant des jeunes j'étais
là-bas et j'ai eu l'occasion de parler
avec plein d'autres jeunes et pleins
d'autres acteurs qui parle au niveau
mondial et je vais aller on va aller
ensemble vers la décroissance on va
faire en sorte que l'on pollue pas la
terre c'est un intérêt commun à nous
tous mais c'était pas très bien reçus
les gens étaient plutôt dans l'idée de
croissance de développement et il faut
comprendre
il y en a qui n'ont rien aujourd'hui des
gens qui vivent dans la pauvreté à un
point de ne pouvoir pas entendre parler
de cette notion diminution du coût moi
je retourne aux études
je me dis que si j'ai pas tout compris
faut que j'apprenne autre chose comment
on va amener ce débat dans la société
elle me suis lancé dans la chaire
d'éthique économique et social pour
comprendre comment le dr no me
fonctionne comment fonctionnent nos
réalités sociales les tensions les
classes sociales le pouvoir politique
sait qu'ils sont là en fait interdisait
questionner cette diminution
en fait derrière toutes ces questions
plutôt social se cache une réalité qu'on
connaît tous aussi c'est que je vous
avais dit c'est pas très compliqué c'est
des inégalités qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
tous les jours les inégalités ici vous
voyez deux chiffres qui sortent début
d'année chaque fois ces chiffres
s'aggrave en plus en fait 62 personnes
c'est moins de personnes que ce que nous
sommes ici nous sommes
puisque 62 il possède autant de
richesses que la moitié du meurtre avait
réussi à monter des humains je crois pas
qu'on les place ici même découpé en
petits morceaux de quelle manière on n'y
arrivera pas du coup c'est l'immensité
de ses inégalités on ne s'en rend pas
compte dans le quotidien on les voit pas
pour faire ça je vous ai amené d'autres
chiffres qui sont les chiffres du crédit
suisse
et on va présenter sa à travers des
bouteilles et des verres
imaginez que chaque verre représente un
nombre d'humains donc là vous voyez un
verre représenterait 30 4 millions
d'humains
si j'en ai 34 millions puis un groupe de
340 millions d'après un groupe où c'est
un peu plus encore
et puis le dernier groupe d'humains
veille sont 30 verre et puis les
derniers eux ils sont 100 vert dans la
sens là ça va prendre un peu plus de
temps désolé alors on arrive à tendance
voilà les derniers sont l'ap
et puis alors les bouteilles que
représentait la richesse qu'ils ont
produit chaque jour peuvent être aussi
mis sur table et là on va aller répartir
comme c'est aujourd'hui c'est la
situation actuelle
chaque bouteille représente donc douze 5
trillions de dollars américains c'est
pour égaliser tout les richesses
nationales
effectivement ici on voit qu'un verre
possèdent ils en font encore encore une
bouteille neuf bouteilles puis on passe
au prochain qui eux en possèdent 8 à 10
et puis finalement on arrive au
troisième groupe qui eux possèdent deux
bouteilles et une petite encore en plus
et puis le dernier groupe
vous l'aurez deviné ils ont même pas une
bouteille en fait ils possèdent une demi
bouteille tous ensemble ça c'est la
situation actuelle
sa citation de notre société dans
laquelle nous vivons
du coup sa commande être embêtant c'est
que en fait si on a diminué le nombre de
bouteilles qu'on boit par rapport à
réalités environnementales
par rapport au réchauffement climatique
je vais vous et à caissons et ça paraît
assez logique armand et c'est embêtant
mais où va-t-on enlever des bouteilles
en fait mon utopie que moi j'ai c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on décide tout sévère
ensemble décident caraman ce qui est ici
ne puisse pas existé ce n'est pas
possible humainement parce qu'il y en a
d'autres qui n'ont rien et parce que
aussi en plus environnementalement honda
diminuer le nombre de bouteilles
du coup si on imagine une décroissance
de la richesse ce qu'étaient les
confusions mémoire et qu'après on assure
que tout le monde ait un minimum on
répartit d'une manière ou d'une autre on
s'assure que ces gens là puissent avoir
un toit de quoi manger ça va limiter les
richesses des plus riches et c'est vrai
que ça questionne nos questions
personnelles nous envient à nous et du
coup pour quand même terminé sur quelque
chose de plus positif
j'ai été chercher aussi des gens qui
parlaient de ces questions là mais d'un
nas fait deux bonnes heures est-ce que
de ceux du coup vu qu'on nous enlève ce
rêve à chacun chacun nous on doit
enlever ce rêve d'un jour est riche
avoir dix mille 10 maisons travaux à
turow quoi qu'on veuille en fait le
bonheur si on y réfléchit bien est
complètement découplé de 7 cette
richesse à partir d'un certain seuil et
in your heart kingman et d'autres ont
déjà fait des études qui montrent que à
partir de 10 mille dollars par an
environ
les gens ils sont satisfaits ils ont
leur maison leur nourriture
ils ont des avis ils savent vivre et
leur bonheur n'est plus du tout couplé à
ceux ci du coup on pourrait même offrir
encore plus pour assurer à chacun
pouvoir accéder à ce bonheur et ça c'est
possible
et d'autres disent en plus que plus
d'égalité et sa cellule qui ne sonne le
pic est entre eux qui ont fait des
études assez pertinente sur sa montre
que plus d'égalité amène aussi plus de
bonheur du coup qu'attendons nous moi je
ne demande qu'une chose si les choses
sont simples à comprendre mais alors
allons-y et changement de notre culture
et faisons ça chacun chez nous et vivons
proche de chez nous sur les rues de
bruxelles par exemple en faisant des
pique niques ou pour sourds à tout autre
endroit où on peut partager des choses
serait taillé les autres qui ne sont pas
liées à la richesse matérielle que qui
détruit la terre et qui empêchent les
autres d'y accéder
voilà c'est ça que j'ai envie de vous
partager de fer avec vous dès que
possible